[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY TRAN: Hey there.
Jimmy, here.
HEATHER CROSS: And hello
again from me, Heather.
On an earlier episode,
we spoke about harnessing
the power of machine learning
with Cloud ML Engine.
Today, we look at how
we can derive insights
from unstructured text
using Google Cloud Natural
Language, a Google Cloud
Machine Learning API.
JIMMY TRAN: We'll also
run through a quick demo
of the self-paced lab, where
we'll ask the Cloud Natural
Language API to extract
entities from a snippet of text.
Let's get to it.
So I have a question for you.
How often do you look
at online reviews
when choosing a restaurant?
HEATHER CROSS: All the
time, especially when
I'm visiting a new city.
JIMMY TRAN: So do I. Well, as
valuable as these insights are
to you as a consumer--
good or bad--
imagine the value to a business
offering a product or service.
HEATHER CROSS: Absolutely.
From online reviews, social
media posts, blogs, forums,
and emails, there's so many ways
to connect the written word.
Think of the amount of
communication data generated
by call centers as well--
a wealth of
business-critical information
just waiting to be extracted.
JIMMY TRAN: An
example of how this
can be helpful in
the real world is,
let's say you're a
business, and you
need to get real-time
answers to questions like,
are my customers happy?
What is being said
about our business?
Or how well is our product
or service being received?
HEATHER CROSS: This is where
Natural Language Processing
is so valuable, as
it allows machines
to analyze huge volumes of
data that humans never could.
Google Cloud Natural Language
reveals the structure
and the meaning of text by
offering powerful machine
learning models in an
easy-to-use REST API.
This API brings you the same
machine learning technology
that powers Google's ability to
find answers in Google search,
and is the system
behind Google Assistant.
You can use the syntax
and sentiment analysis
functionalities of
Cloud Natural Language
to extract linguistic
information in a block of text,
as well as the overall
feelings expressed with it.
JIMMY TRAN: You can
also use entity analysis
to return information
about known entities,
such as public figures,
landmarks, organizations,
products, and so on.
Positive, negative,
or neutral sentiments
can be identified by
combining sentiment analysis
to these entities too.
HEATHER CROSS: And if you're
in an industry like media
or publishing, where
you would traditionally
have manually sorted, labeled,
and categorized content,
the Natural Language API
can also automatically sort
documents and content into more
than 700 predefined categories
for you.
JIMMY TRAN: Time for Qwik labs.
In this hands-on lab, you'll
use the Cloud Natural Language
API to extract entities like
people, places, and events
from a snippet of text.
HEATHER CROSS: You
can check out the link
to start the Qwik lab here.
Keep in mind that this will take
about 40 minutes to complete.
So far in the lab,
we've created an API key
so that we can use the analyze
entities Natural Language API
method.
With this method, the API can
extract entities like people,
places, and events from text.
We're going to try out
the entity analysis
with the sentence, "Michelangelo
Caravaggio, Italian painter,
is known for The
Calling of St. Matthew."
First, we're
building our request
to the Natural Language
API in the request.json
file in the Cloud Shell editor.
We can then pass the
request body along
with the API key environment
variable to the Natural
Language API with
this cURL command.
The response shows us the entity
type metadata-- in this case,
a Wikipedia URL--
and [INAUDIBLE]---- the indices
of where the entity appears
in the text from 0 to 1.
And with that, we've sent our
first request to the Cloud
Natural Language API.
JIMMY TRAN: So that brings us
to an end of another episode.
We hope you enjoyed it.
If you found some cool ways to
apply the Natural Language API,
we'd love to hear from you.
HEATHER CROSS: And
make sure to check out
the link where you
can apply what you've
learned using the $300 free
trial credit on Google Cloud
Platform here.
JIMMY TRAN: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks for watching
and see you soon.